Lagertha from Vikings is one of the most
iconic warrior women
in television history.
Millions watched her lead armies divorce
Ragnar and rule as Queen.
The show's creators said they
based her on real medieval sources. So I
read those sources. The
actual medieval account
written 400 years after the Viking Age
ended by a Christian cleric with an
agenda. And it tells
a completely different story than what
made it to the screen.
The show makes female Viking
warriors look uncommon but accepted. The
medieval source presents
Lagertha as proof that pagan
society was barbaric. And modern
archaeologists just found a female
warrior grave that's forcing
historians to rethink everything. So
which version is true? In the show
Lagertha is Ragnar's first
wife. A shield maiden who fights in the
shield wall. She divorces
Ragnar, becomes Earl, then Queen.
The medieval source Lagertha tests Ragnar
by making him fight a
bear and a dog. He divorces
her because she tried to kill him with
those animals. She later
murders her second husband
with a spearhead hidden in her dress. One
of these is fiction. The
other one is closer to reality.
Let me show you which one. Vikings
premiered in 2013. Lagertha,
played by Catherine Winnick,
became the breakout character. She's
portrayed as Ragnar's equal.
She fights in the shield wall
during the first raid on England. When
Ragnar takes his second wife she divorces
him. She becomes Earl
of Hetibi, later Queen of Kattegat. The
show treats her warrior
status as uncommon but not
shocking. Men respect her combat skills.
She is a political leader
who happens to be female.
Articles called her the most powerful
woman on television. She
became a symbol of female
empowerment. They based her on a medieval
text called the Gestada
Norum. So what does that text
the Gestada Norum. So what does that text
actually say? The Gestada
actually say? The Gestada Norum, deeds of
the Danes, was written
around 1200 by Saxo Grammaticus.
Grammaticus. He worked for
He worked for the Archbishop of Lund and
wrote to glorify Danish Christian kings.
That's roughly 200 years
That's roughly 200 years after the Viking
Age ended. Imagine
someone today writing about the
1800s based entirely on oral tradition.
oral tradition. That's the
That's the gap we're
dealing with. According to Saxo,
Saxo, Lagertha first appears when
Lagertha first appears when Norwegian
noblewomen grabbed weapons to defend
themselves. He describes
describes her as a skilled Amazon who,
her as "a skilled Amazon who, though a
maiden, had the courage of a
man". Notice that phrasing.
phrasing. Not "she was courageous,
Not "she was courageous". She had the
courage of a man. Her
gender is the scandalous part.
is the scandalous part. After the battle,
After the battle, Ragnar sends messengers
to court her. But
Lagertha tests him. She places
places a bear and a dog
a bear and a dog at her home's entrance.
at her home's entrance. Ragnar has to
Ragnar has to kill them
both. He thrust one through with
a spear and caught the other one by the
throat, wrung its neck and
choked it. If that sounds more
If that sounds more like a
like a fairy tale than history, hold that
thought. They marry and
have three children. They live
together for three years. Then Ragnar
divorces her because she long ago set the
most savage beasts to
most savage beasts to destroy
destroy him. He is still mad about the
bear and the dog. Years later, when
Ragnar faces rebellion,
Ragnar faces rebellion, Lagertha
Lagertha responds with a fleet of 120
ships. During the battle, she flies to
the rear of the enemy
to the rear of the enemy and
and turns the tide. After this victory,
turns the tide. After this victory, she
she returns home and
murders her second husband.
She hides a spearhead in her dress and
kills him in his sleep. Saxo
writes that she "usurpped the
whole of his name and sovereignty" and
calls her a "most presumptuous dame".
calls her a most presumptuous dame.
Notice the tone he's
condemning her. She's portrayed as
unnatural and morally wrong
for seizing power. Because Saxo
Grammaticus was a Christian cleric,
writing centuries after
the Viking Age. His book is
propaganda to make Danish kings look good
and Norse pagans look
barbaric. When Saxo writes about
warrior women, he's using them as
examples of pagan chaos. The first nine
books of the Gestora
Norum are considered largely fictional.
fictional. They're legendary sagas, not
They're legendary sagas,
not historical accounts.
historical accounts.
Most scholars say Lagertha was probably a
mythological figure, possibly the goddess
possibly the goddess Torgerd mixed with
Torgerd mixed with classical Amazon
stories. In the late 1800s,
archaeologists excavated a
grave in Birka, Sweden, located on a
prominent hill and buried in
a wooden chamber, absolutely
absolutely packed with military
packed with military equipment. A sword,
equipment. A sword, an axe, a fighting
an axe, a fighting knife, two
spearheads, iron bosses from
two shields, 25 armor-piercing arrows
with shafts decorated in
silver thread, plus two horses,
plus two horses, a mare and a stallion.
a mare and a stallion. And there's one
more critical detail.
Sitting in the deceased lab was a full
Sitting in the deceased lab was
a full set of Viking chess pieces, 28
whalebone warriors and three
walrus ivory dice. In the Viking
world, these gaming pieces
world, these gaming pieces represented
military strategy. This
wasn't just a warrior burial,
This wasn't just a warrior burial, this
this was a military commander, not just a
fighter, but a tactician
who understood strategy and
a tactician who understood strategy and
command. For over a century, everyone
assumed this was a male
warrior. The material culture
screamed professional
screamed "professional military
commander". Then in 2017, researchers
published DNA analysis,
researchers published DNA analysis. The
the study "A Female Viking Warrior
Confirmed by Genomics". The
DNA showed no Y chromosome.
the DNA showed no Y chromosome. The
The skeleton was female, a woman in her
30s or 40s, not just a warrior, a
military strategist,
strategist, a tactician. The burial
a tactician. The burial wasn't random,
wasn't random. Someone
someone carefully arranged
these objects, the chess pieces
in her lap, the sword by her left hip,
the elaborate knife on her right side.
the elaborate knife on
her right side. She was
buried wearing clothing with silver
embroidery, fashions from the
Eurasian steppe. Next to her
to her skull, a silver cone that
skull, a silver cone that decorated a
Slavic-style cab. This woman
had traveled and when she died,
died, her community buried
her community buried her with full
military honors. Birka isn't completely
alone. Archaeologists have
Archaeologists have found about a dozen
found about a dozen other Viking age
women buried with weapons. In Kopan,
Norway, two women in a
boat grave with spears. In Gedrup,
In Gedrup, Denmark, a woman with a
Denmark, a woman with a
spearhead. In Klimta, Sweden,
spearhead. In Klimta, Sweden, a woman's
a woman's cremation grave with an axe.
axe. But here's the catch. Every single
But here's the catch, every
single grave is debatable.
grave is debatable. An axe
An axe could be for chopping firewood, a
domestic tool. That spear
could be a ritual magic staff,
ritual magic staff, not a weapon.
not a weapon. Scholars have argued about
these graves for decades.
about these graves for decades. Were
Were these women warriors,
these women warriors or
or were the weapons symbolic? But Birka
is different. This
wasn't a single axe or a
debatable spear. This was a sword, an
axe, a knife, two spears,
a knife, two spears, two shields, 25
two shields, 25 arrows, horses,
arrows, horses and a
and a full set of gaming pieces. If this
burial was just
symbolic of family status,
family status, they
they committed hard to the bit. So what's
the actual truth about
Lagertha? The TV show?
About 80% fiction. It borrowed Lagertha's
name and the concept, then
invented almost everything
else. The medieval source? Also fiction,
Also fiction, just older fiction. Written
just older fiction.
Written two centuries later by
a Christian cleric using warrior women as
propaganda. Lagertha
was probably mythological,
mythological. Based on the goddess
based on the goddess Torgerd mixed with
Amazon stories filtered
through religious bias. But
bias. But the archaeology?
the archaeology? That's real. The Birka
grave proves at least one
Viking woman held warrior
held warrior status in the
status in the 10th century. Viking women
had more legal rights than
most medieval European women.
Some probably learned weapon skills. And
at least one was buried
like a military commander.
But Viking society was still patriarchal.
Warfare was primarily male.
Warfare was primarily male. The fact that
The fact that Saxo wrote about
Lagertha at all suggests she was
remarkable because she was unusual. So
here's the uncomfortable
So here's the uncomfortable reality.
reality. Lagertha was probably just a
story medieval Christians
told about pagan ancestors,
told about pagan ancestors. Filtered
filtered through biases mixed with
mythology, shaped by propaganda. But
here's what matters.
But here's what matters. At least one
At least one Viking woman held warrior
status. At least one was
buried with the honors of a
buried with the honors of a military
military strategist. The TV show got that
part right. Even if
everything else was fiction.
else was fiction. The truth is messier
The truth is messier than Hollywood and
honestly that makes it more interesting.
interesting. If you are here for the
If you are here for the history without
the bullshit, hit
subscribe. Every week I break
I break down what really happened and
down what really happened and what we
just wished it. I'll
see you in the next one.